زخم لافت في الصناعات العسكريه في النسخه
الثانيه لمعرض الدفاع الدولي بمدينه
الرياض اكثر من 700 عارض من دول مختلفه
ابرزها الولايات المتحده والصين وبريطانيا
اضافه الى تركيا قدموا منتجات تسليحه
متعدده في صناعه الدفاع والامن في معرض
يسعى القائمون عليه الى جعله منصه عالميه
تجمع المصنعين وصناع القرار في هذا
القطاع هناك فرص كبيره جدا في قطاع طبعا
الصناعات العسكريه وايضا هناك فرص كبيره
في العمل من القطاع المدني لتقديم حلول
وخدمات وايضا المشاركه
في قطاع الصناعات العسكريه وتطوير
القدرات يدخلون مع الشركات الكبرى التي
تورد
لمختلف الجهات العسكريه
السعوديه بالجانب التطوير وال البحث
والتطوير والابتكار ايضا هناك الحقيقه
شفنا امثله رائعه من شباب وشابات سعوديين
يعني استطاعوا ولله الحمد
انهم يعني ينتجون
منتجات يقبلها السوق و تحل كثير من
المشاكل الشركات السعوديه المنخرط في
الصناعات والخدمات العسكريه ارتفع عددها
الى
266 شركه تحمل
477 ترخيصا في التصنيع العسكري رقم يشير
الى ان استثمارات القطاع الخاص السعودي في
المجالات العسكريه ماضيه في خط تصاعدي
وعلى هامش المعرض ابرمت 61 اتفاقيه ومذكره
تفاهم بقيمه تجاوزت
25 مليار ريال سعودي وقعت وزاره الدفاع
على هامش المعرض العديد من العقود مع
الشركات المحليه والعالميه بتكلفه عاليه
جدا والاهم فيها هي عقود المشاركه
التصنيعيه اللي تمت مع بعض بين بعض هذه
الشركات والهيئه العامه للصناعات العسكريه
بهدف توطين هذه الصناعات داخل المملكه وفي
ظل انفتاح العالم على الاستثمار في بيع
تقنيات تصنيع الاسلحه جاء هذا المعرض
ليؤكد اهميه تطوير الدول للصناعات
العسكريه وهو توجه بدا جليا في سباق
التصنيع العسكري الذي تعكسه اجنحه الدول
المشاركه في المعرض فتح هذا المعرض الباب
امام دول كثيره لعرض قدراتها في التصنيع
العسكري في وقت تشهد فيه المنطقه والعالم
حروبا وتوترات فالحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
وقبلها الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه غيرتا
كثيرا من موازين الردع وفرضت معادلات
جديده في العالم جعلت من السلاح اولويه
قصوى بدر ربيعان
الجزيره
الرياض